hi welcome back this is a follow-up to
the video on pop science so if you
haven't seen that go watch that right
now I just want to discuss a few ideas a
few things got they got left out of the
video the first of which is Josh Kaufman
now Josh wrote a follow-up to Malcolm
Gladwell's piece outliers and his 10,000
hour roll the 10,000 hour rule if you
don't know is the idea that to be an
expert in any given field it takes
roughly 10,000 hours of practice this
has been sociological research that's
been done and it's basically built on
some actual data but Josh Kaufman
decided that he was gonna make his own
role and he called it the 20-hour role
which he says will get you good at
anything here's what his idea basically
says if you put 20 hours of focused
deliberate practice into that thing you
will be astounded astounded at how good
you are now like Gladwell Josh Kaufman
says his discovery is backed by research
how long does it take from starting
something and being grossly incompetent
and knowing it to being reasonably good
how long does that take
here's what my research says 20 hours
now
what is that research well besides a few
charts that he puts up about it about
the bell curve of learning you if you go
to his book if you buy his book like I
did for like 15 bucks you find out that
it's all based on his personal
experience as in he literally the book
if I can spoil it for you spoiler
warning is just him learning six
different skills deciding that the
average of those skills to get good
enough however good he wanted to be was
20 hours and then he just called it the
20-hour roll got a TED talk got a TED
talk from like the becoming bad at the
ukulele kiteboarding chess yoga I went
to have random skills and he just
translates this and says like oh yeah
this is this is the new rule it's not a
rule it's not a rule it's just his
personal it's like his personal motto
you could almost call it no one in that
audience realizes that this is not a
scientific backed claim or anything like
that it's
just it's just his opinion it's actually
unbelievable that that got however many
views on YouTube it's like in the
millions millions of people saw that and
thought to themselves there's something
called the 20-hour rule that can teach
you to in Josh's words learn to juggle
flaming chainsaws as long as you give 20
hours to something want to learn a
language want to learn how to draw want
to learn how to juggle flaming chainsaws
so just absurd and it just goes to show
as long as you just say it's backed by
research it doesn't actually have to be
it can be backed by personal experience
as long as you just say it it passes the
next idea I want to talk about is Adam
grant or back to him and his study of
web browsers so in his book and in his
TED talk it's the second point of his
book he says that web browsers what web
browser you use can actually determine
how good of a worker you are we can
predict your job performance and your
commitment just by knowing what web
browser you use there is good evidence
that Firefox and Chrome users
significantly outperform Internet
Explorer and Safari users they also stay
in their jobs 15% longer by the way no
this is obviously a super interesting
claim but where is the data behind this
right like proving causality in
sociology and and and in big data is
really hard so you know how did he do
this well I went to Adam grant and I
said where is this data that you did
where's the methodology he told me well
I don't have it go to the original guy
who made it right and this his book says
this too was done by this guy Michael
hazard so ok ok I go to Michael Houseman
so I contact Michael Houseman I say hey
where's this data you did he said oh
well I don't have it you have to go ask
my a former employer where I did the
work it's probably become a white paper
there
so I go to cornerstone OnDemand and I
asked them hey where's this paper that
Michael Hausman did he used to work for
you they said oh we have no idea what
you're talking about we don't know where
this white paper is either so they don't
know so I go back to grant and I say hey
this the second argument of your book
nobody knows what the paper is no one
knows where the data is he says oh well
if house me can't help you I can't help
you so I guess we're out of luck
which is insane right because you read
that and you just naturally assume all
these figures are used about all the
controls they did all the research they
did but it's like where is this it's not
publicly accessible in fact even the
authors don't have access to the work
anymore so we just gonna I don't know
take it for granted that this work was
perfectly controlled I mean are you
kidding me and this this data was talked
about I mean in the Atlantic those
talked about in freakonomics it was
talked about in Adam grants book never
was any actual paper produced I mean
never was the result only the results
were trotted out none of the data was
actually ever visible I don't know maybe
I'm being a little too critical I truly
do believe that people like grant and
these writers are the best in pop
science the reason I say that is because
they have the most references of
probably anybody I mean if you take like
your average this is sort of part of the
ribbon this is part of the reason I
didn't talk about youtubers too much is
because youtubers are sort of
second-tier in pops I'm generally
broadly speaking because you take your
average youtuber what are we gonna make
maybe a 10 minute video maybe a 20
minute video a book is several times
that length you just get way more time
to talk about ideas people spend way
more time writing about those ideas and
people spend way more time researching
about those ideas I mean even you know
my last video I have a ton of references
in it but maybe the references would
span a page to give you some context
grant he had 30 pages of references in
originals like I think a tenth of his
book was references so just to put
YouTube in context at YouTube is like
well below pop side books and so that's
why we really didn't talk about it but
it's worth saying that like yeah if you
think you're youtubers like myself are
somehow better than better than these
writers you couldn't be more wrong the
last thing I want to discuss is the idea
that I heard from somebody who studies
this stuff for a living methodological
problems in science what he told me is
that it's not so much that right these
writers are doing these things
intentionally right they're not doing
these things malicious
he was telling me that basically it's
just the problem of everyone has a job
to do and everyone has incentives within
those jobs which we've sort of discussed
but consider that when you're when
you're a scientist right and you're
trying to move up in the ranks what
moves you up is publishing and the thing
about publishing is journals like it
especially the better journals like it
if you have some sensational results so
you have this like little incentive to
sort of fudge the data here maybe not
intentionally do it but maybe even look
for the more exciting data so you do
that as a scientist then the science
editor of your University he comes to
uni says hey what do you have for me you
tell him about your new exciting article
and he has to frame that in a way that
the wider world will care about and
maybe a HuffPo will pick up or the
Atlantic will pick up so he writes he
maybe fudges that he massages the
wording a little bit to make your
finding a little more sensational than
it is
then once the science editor is done
then he goes on to maybe a pot either an
article or goes on to like a pop science
writer where the same thing is repeated
people maybe forget about this nuance
forget about like that little caveat
there and focus on like the main the
main claim of the thing and try to make
this sensational thing out of it and it
keeps just filtered filter filter filter
filter meanwhile the data is usually not
being gone back and checked on because
people just naturally assume oh the
person who did it knew what they were
doing and at the end what you have is
just this long game of telephone where
everybody is sort of manipulating the
story leaving things out here
emphasizing these things in order to
play into what they're trying to say or
what their jobs demanding of them and
that just produces a lot of simplified
answers and sometimes misleading answers
not always because the better obviously
there are better and worse actors in all
of this there are people who are aware
of all these incentives and try to fight
them that's not my point my point is
just these incentives are there and
because they're there
these things do slip through so what do
we do about this unfortunately I think a
lot of this is inevitable right you the
people who are qualified on it the
experts generally are either bad
communicators or they're they spend so
much time explaining all the new ones
that people who aren't interested and on
the other hand the people who are good
at communicating tend not to be experts
in all the fields that they are talking
about so you just always are going to
have this sort of disconnect and as the
viewer you just have to be informed that
this is a thing that happens and you
have to be skeptical when people make
claims anyway I don't want to go too
long on this I just wanted to get some
other ideas out there and just say by no
means where the last was the last videos
examples like the only thing in pop
science there are actually too many
examples to count but I just wanted to
give you a few more to get your hands on
give you so few more ideas to think
about and yeah I thanks for listening to
my pops I leftovers and I hope to see
you in the next video subscribe
subscribe to the other channel I'll see
you soon
[Music]